do you really want the state telling
adults what they can and cannot consume
and do you want them telling certain
because plenty of adults will be able to
continue to buy cigarettes it is their
peers who won't be able to buy
cigarettes and for me that is a that is
a huge inequality it's a huge problem
and it's also a playbook for a labor
party that might decide to tackle food
that might decide to tackle alcohol that
might decide that they want to Target
whatever they consider to be dangerous
at the time so you know it might not be
cigarettes for our viewers watching it
might be something else and I I don't
think they should assume that that's
safe from The Nanny State when there's
this new playbook going around that just
says well you don't like it ban it for
people who can't vote yet ban it for
people who can't be pulled yet who don't
have a voice who don't have a say I
think it's really important in a free
society that we stand up and it's
difficult that we stand up for the bad
options sometimes